لكن الانفجار المروع الذي وقع في
مخيم جباليا للاجئين في شمال غزة شمال
مدينة غزة، وصف أحد الشهود لشبكة CNN
أنه بدا وكأنه نهاية
العالم وأن سبعة إلى ثمانية
حفر في الأرض كانت مليئة
بأجزاء من أجساد القتلى.
في المكان ندى بشير من سي إن إن لديها
المزيد عن الغارة الجوية الإسرائيلية أه
نريد أن نحذر مشاهدينا من أن الصور
في هذا التقرير هي
مشاهد مرعبة مزعجة للغاية من
اليأس المطلق أين هي يتوسل هذا الرجل ولكن
كل شيء هنا
ذهب جزء من لاجئ جباليا  تحول الآن مخيم
من بين أكبر المخيمات وأكثرها كثافة
سكانية في غزة إلى أنقاض، وهو
أحدث هدف للحملة الجوية الإسرائيلية المتواصلة، وقد
أعلن جيش الدفاع الإسرائيلي
مسؤوليته عن الغارة الجوية على
الهدف الذي يقولون إنه قُتل فيه قائد كبير في حماس
في الانفجار، وركزنا
مرة أخرى على هدف.
قائد كبير لكن هذا الهجوم وهذه
المذبحة كما يصفها الأطباء في غزة
أصابت المدنيين
بشدة، وعملت فرق الاستجابة للطوارئ
بشكل يائس على أمل العثور على المزيد من
الناجين ولكن خارج
المستشفى الإندونيسي المكتظ بجثث غزة تصطف في
الشارع وعدد القتلى
والجرحى وفقًا  إلى
مدير المستشفيات الموجودة بالفعل في
[موسيقى]
المئات من الأمهات داخل المستشفى
مع أطفالهن المصابين
والمصابين بصدمات نفسية، لكن الناجين في الخارج
يواصلون الحفر بين أنقاض
ما كانت منازلهم ذات يوم يائسين
للعثور على أحبائهم مدفونين تحتها ولكنهم جميعًا
يخشون
الأسوأ.  من مقاطع الفيديو التي
ظهرت في أعقاب
الغارة الجوية على جباليا هي ببساطة رسومية للغاية
بحيث
لا يمكن إظهارها للأطباء، حيث أخبروا شبكة CNN أنه تم العثور على الجثث متفحمة ومقطعة إلى أجزاء. ويأتي هذا الكابوس بعد أن حذرت إسرائيل سكان نورلاند غزة من الإخلاء باتجاه الجنوب، لكن الكثير منهم ببساطة لا يستطيعون ذلك  ارحلوا، وبينما تنفي إسرائيل
تنفيذ عقوبات جماعية
ضد الشعب الفلسطيني، لكن
مشاهد كهذه تنعكس في جميع أنحاء
قطاع غزة تظهر أن المدنيين هم
الذين يدفعون الثمن